[Music]
widely regarded as one of the greatest
English novelists of our time
Dame Hillary mantel's books redefined
how we think of the historical novel you
say that if I die he can put another
queen in my place
no one will ever take her place the
queen of bringing the path to life
winning the book a prize twice for her
Wolf Hall Trilogy a fictional account of
Thomas cromwell's rise to power adapted
for screen stage and selling to date
more than 5 million copies worldwide
meticulously researched immensely
popular
she found Fame as an author later in
life at University she'd studied law
later becoming a film critic for The
Spectator
name Hillary mantel for services to
literature writing 17 books she received
a damehood in 2014 for services to
literature it seems to me there's a
point
in your life
when you hear an inner prompt
and it says choose your weapons
this [ __ ]
mightier than the sword
the author was asked in an interview
earlier this month whether she believed
in an afterlife she said she did but she
couldn't imagine how it might work
adding however the universe is not
limited by what I can imagine
but it was both her imagination and
phenomenal historical Insight which
marked Dame Hillary mantel out as a
unique literary voice one of the
Century's finest writers whose work will
be read for centuries to come Katie
Spencer Sky News